he goes like this put his arm around
they're setting up for the picture and
and joe pesci says hey
he said i said i take the picture get
your [ __ ] arm off
right
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god
with me george lopez
sport sport sporting paul
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george
george lopez oh my god omg omg hi oh my
god
you driven around in the middle of the
night
yeah it's
we were driving
through that area
and there was
a bush area like into like north
carolina
coming down so you know the two-lane
highway over there like south of the
border that place yes yes yes
i said we have to go in there
that place is legendary oh legendary
there's a place called uh how would you
describe it it's like but there it's
it's [ __ ] ghosty little attraction
it's the border of south of north
carolina south of the border they call
it south of the border because there you
can buy fireworks legally so that's
their hook is like oh you finally made
it get your fireworks and then it's like
hey south of the border let's go with
the mexican theme and have the big
mexican dude
[Laughter]
and they have they have billboards
leading up to it
for about 50 miles yeah say like really
yeah so by the time you get to like 25
miles
yeah you're like like mecca we're going
and then you start to see this guy
what's this does he have a name i don't
know i think i popped in there one time
and it was a ghost town i'm like
maybe it was just maybe it was just bad
weather or something but it was dead i
got some fireworks they have like a
hotel yeah there's a hotel a restaurant
yeah a gift shop yeah
that's a little touristy if you wanted
to buy souvenirs that looked like the
people that we grew up around [ __ ]
great place
to get there to get a coffee mug of your
uncle that passed in the early 70s
with the little paper thin mustache kind
of [ __ ] hungover an ashtray i got an
ashtray at the house
a stationary pad a notepad with a little
mexican dude with a sombrero
get buy beans dude i gotta check that
out again i moved back north carolina
about three years ago and so i travel
around there all the time i gotta i
gotta stop back in there and you know
it's still there i just haven't been in
and i would say look at this and you
know clearly something that's biased
towards latinos and the lady would say
that that's one of our top sellers like
nobody
nobody saw some [ __ ] like
that would say like this kind of oh
we're sorry we didn't know you were
coming but they're like there's only two
i don't know what size you want but
they're only just a few sizes left
and i got a mug at the house and uh nice
a little doll i bought for my uh for my
dog that's walking around with it in its
mouth like a little pepe guy with that
sombrero
uh yeah driving at night they're like uh
you gotta watch out for deer
i mean i've hit where they come out of
it yeah they're just like kamikaze
trying to you hit someone with your
truck
or your car i had a yeah i had a deer
with uh my i used to have a suzuki
sidekick
okay so it was like a box who lived dude
it was like a [ __ ] box kite that's
hilarious it is
yeah and i hit that thing and totaled my
car why did you get a suzuki was it was
it uh does it have to be closer or not
because you know college let's go
through our first cars and let's see why
we ended up with the cars we ended up
with so a suzuki samurai yes suzuki
sidekick sidekick that was a little
bigger than the samurai oh there was a
samurai yeah samurai was a two-door
sidekick was a four-door when you went
to the lottery they tell you that's one
of our biggest sellers
[Laughter]
two sizes left i thought like well this
will be a fun little car to have in
college i can tailgate i can get friends
in the back i can put a keg of beer back
here
and uh nothing about learning either so
no no nothing about my books you know i
can keep my books in there
i think i picked it because it was red
too and it was just the school color so
i'm like oh yeah it's red was it you
when you bought it or no i got it new oh
that's not my first car though but i did
love that where's your first car my
first car was a 1982 berlinetta camaro
remember
um oh yeah 82 is when they um i think it
was maybe the last year of that body
style and then they changed in 83. what
body style was that it's like a smooth
glass top t-top oh no my brother had my
brother had a iroc z28 with t-tops
yeah i was jealous of that car
yeah like smoking the banded car it was
blue but kind of smoking the bennett was
a trans am this was an iroc they look
very high rock yeah and iraq
yeah
the it's i think it stood for italian
racing
it stood for something
right but did it even have eye rocks
anymore i don't see the word iroc you
know let's talk about american cars i
think they
they we [ __ ] it up somewhere along the
way maybe
steel or but listen
my first car was a 51 chevy that i used
to call the green hornet it was an ugly
ass green but it was given to me but was
that factory green
yeah yeah
and but
it was a gift my brother-in-law gave him
he had a
uh junkyard
and this was one that would trade it in
they put it together gave him my car
that was it man i would have me a car
had me ride a free car he gave it to you
yeah gave it to me
freebie and what was it again a green
hornet well i called it the green hornet
yeah it was a piece of [ __ ] it would
break down on a rope yeah by the way
iraq international race of champions
that's what it was the international
race of champions
look like was there an 85 uh iraq z28
that was my brother's car i was so
jealous it was badass first of all
that's a great [ __ ] title for a car
too by the way there you go uh i rock
z28 camaro
yeah
it sounds like a
like some sort of helicopter and the
army would have yeah yeah that thing is
that ring which one's yours
the
my brothers would be that black one
right there oh pretty much except it was
it was blue
mine was the 82 camaro not the iroc not
the z28 it was a little
less than that but we also had
personalized license plates like right
when you could do that yeah like it
wasn't a thing until like maybe that
year i got a car and they said you could
do what you want i was like i put my
name on there so all mine said was john
rape nothing clever
not a nickname my damn name yeah that's
the dumbest thing did anybody put their
[ __ ] name on the just john reeves
they put reaper
right my brother was
reapster reapster yeah
he put his [ __ ] name john reeves john
yeah who did this to my yard well john
rainbow whole thing man killed out you
know you might be the only person i ever
heard of that put their name on there
you can't put your address too many
[ __ ] letters yeah you can put your
name mine fit
j-o-n with a space and then r-e-e-p it
looked like a name tag did you have a
personal plate i had a personal plate
and [ __ ] a lot of it meets a lot
took a lot of [ __ ] from my personal
plate there was a female
uh the worked homicide bureau she was
single and she had ms
ms 187 over here 187 is a penal code
section for murder yeah we were working
is it murder in north
carolina 187.
i know snoop dogg so i thought it'd be
cool i put i had one mr 187
and i took more [ __ ] from the guys at
the bureau because like hey
who do you think you are some arrogant
pompous piece of [ __ ] that you're mr
money
yeah yeah
or yeah yeah
or mstr
no mr
was a space in there so it was
and i took it off
did you ask for it no i asked for it i
wanted it okay but i i didn't feel like
taking the heat anymore yeah yeah what
year was that
that's probably about 86 87.
and yours
mine was uh i got that car in 88. it was
at 82. i got an 80. i put it on a
a new chevy
85.
and that i had bought during the night
stock investigation and what'd you put
there i got i put mr 187 on the car got
him
what was your first car
my grandmother had a 19
buick riviera wow that was a nice car
that had it looked like a matchstick on
the on the speedometer and if you went
past 65 you could set the time it
you went to let you know you're going
over the speed limit had a little thing
had a match it was a yellow
point a ball on the little stick and you
could put it at 70 and if you got past
70 it went
and you
and they [ __ ] it up because they went
to tijuana and got the front seat
reupholstered
with
some jade green saran wrap that looked
like rubber like if you tear a balloon
and you stretch it
and my grandmother sat down in the tour
you know what was in there [ __ ] bags
of rice rolled up newspaper no cushion
[Laughter]
[ __ ] newspapers a [ __ ] torn
blanket
some [ __ ] rice
cheers
i like it because of my backpack it
feels good i came right back like it's
got a little protective [ __ ] bag of
rice
trash they filled it up with [ __ ]
trash
my buddy uh when i got married
he drove me in a black uh beautiful
buick riviera
that was our it was a great it was a
what does that look like can you like
[ __ ] it looks like you put those hey so
so
i ended up with it with the with the
when you sat down you almost
you almost had to like hold the wheel to
where you couldn't put your whole weight
on and you tear them
you fall through
no no
okay and then they change the back to
make it look like it was almost like a
batmobile they [ __ ] that up but but uh
yeah oh this guy is that oh oh my god
dude right there that is bad and the
lights popped up
that is badass that was it was it was a
bad he had a badass car and for a
mexican to have that car a young guy
i mean it was
would you want that like if you could
get your first car back like somehow
track it down fix it
would you do it i think so yeah because
the jade green
jade green
was that's
like a nice dark green and the rims and
you know one time i went to mexico and i
saw this lady sweeping the a dirt floor
but like really working hard i've seen
it then and
you know it's all in perspective you
know i saw this guy washing his car
and it he'd take him four hours and it
was a piece of [ __ ] yeah but to him in
his mind it was like a car i don't think
i think our
are romanticizing a car right that it
may not be
a bentley
but to you and the to the time that that
guy spent in that car i'm like what is
this [ __ ] scene that i'm not
seeing yeah my wife used to make fun she
was my girlfriend then she used to make
fun of my car because it's such a piece
of [ __ ] we went to alvarez street one
time and i had her cousin with us
busy down here from texas we went to
obera street pulled into the parking lot
the guy said no no no no no
he did over here over here
he sent me across the street this car
was so ugly
yeah
yeah but those that's like you know
that's all you have that's the your
first car that's your baby and maybe you
you spent
a lot of money on it and like i'm going
to take care of it you know i see people
who get get cars and they just they
trash them that's but you know like we
had
i mean i had sperm stains in the back
seat the guys would go back here
in high school man they'd go back there
that's why you have a buick
but you know what i mean like if you
guys are back there looking at [ __ ]
you know i mean oh man
that's not all jp nasty man i mean
so so
i had a uh i bought a uh
toyota celica at hamer toyota on sepolar
like
about half a mile from my house
um
and i got a license plate that said one
liners l-i-n-e-r-z
okay four people were using z's
before rap before boys in the hood even
though it was cool
before it was called the lady goes you
know this is it's supposed to be an s
yeah
oh that's dope
my plate has a z in it now
oh yeah what is it
papa gills
wow
do you have a personalized thing now no
yeah i try not to put my license plates
on
because
of uh i see how long i can go without
putting it on it's a good shake well
here you have to go front and back right
yeah yeah north carolina's just the back
did you ever put a did you ever put a
beer you ever take a buy a case of beer
and then take your frame and then cut
the name of the beer and put the beer in
front of your front plate
as like your license plate oh i've seen
that
uh i've not done it i did it with
that [ __ ] moose head
i cut out i was out in tent too man
cutting with a steak knife around the
thing moose said i put it in there i get
out probably a mile from the house
pulled over
[ __ ] says hey is moose head a
[ __ ] license plate
thing [ __ ] pulled it off oh and threw
it in the back seat and wrote me up and
said you need a front plate right right
i was cool
i [ __ ] was a mile value off of the
house
yeah that's
from a cop's point of view in the old
days i mean that's like that's just a
good stuff why yeah why is that because
you have to be able to see what
well the law says thinking from a cop's
point of view the law says you have to
have front and back
from a cop point of view you want to
pull over see who's driving that car see
what they're up to
you need that that probable cause
there's the violation yeah you've only
got one place one plate that's a gimmick
yeah that's a stop that guy justified
pulling yeah let's just stop see what's
going on would you put on the euro could
put a confederate flag you could tell us
no but i see them that's stupid there's
like three all around here what did the
confederate flag become i mean i love
[ __ ] leonard skinner they had a big
ass
i didn't have a problem dude
lisa hazard leonard skinner kid rock i
never had a problem with it i mean
i mean [ __ ] it i never had a problem
with the confetti and the problem with
the american flag or don't tread on me
or or i never had problems i wasn't
smart enough i never had problem with
the confederate flag or anything i did
have problems when i was in georgia
where they had in 69 it was still
segregated so they had whites only
colors black yeah so but i didn't pay
attention to the flags i i didn't yeah i
didn't know my history
just looking at the confederate flag if
you just look at it and and just like
like you don't know what the history is
it just looks badass because it's an x
with stars on it it looks what is it
called bars and stars stars and bars
stars is it all
stars and bars people can evil rock that
[ __ ] dude kind of yeah he had like a big
he was beloved i i i like who's the uh
the guy that uh
god damn how come i never remember this
[ __ ] is it your father
no he was a nascar
dale earnhardt
richard petty they made movies about him
he was always the sheriff was jackie
gleason was always after him oh bro i
spoke to the bandit smoking the bandit
yeah the best oh my god that was that
was bad becky gleason steals
paul williams
and those guys were already like stars
but they created characters that you
went to the movie theater you forgot
that paul williams was a singer and he
was just kind of this little daddy's boy
i growing up i didn't know him as a
singer because i was a little i guess
i'm a little bit younger where i when
he'd come up on the screen i didn't know
him as a singer i just thought he was a
funny little short actor oh man yeah i
was like he's great
johnny carson i thought anything he was
going to get in chingazoo you need a
fight right there on johnny carson
somebody making fun of him right one of
the guests
and he [ __ ] stood up and we'll get
him right he's a little [ __ ] too yeah
yeah yeah he played in my golf
tournament man uh uh like a few years
ago because he was friends with freddie
prinze used to open
prints it open for him so i invited paul
and yeah he played and uh
i mean legends man yeah i mean legends
just scene where jackie gleason gets out
my [ __ ]
and then the outtakes at the end yeah i
mean okay so so let's look at that and
if we all went to the theater everybody
would be laughing
nobody would be hissing nobody'd get up
and walk out it was a [ __ ] huge hit
there was no
talk about race or discrimination
or
um
biased in anything it was comedy yeah it
was just a flat out it was flat out yeah
funny they did deprecating yeah i'd go
see a good comedy movie
minimal two times two three four times
and it was funny because we'd be in the
theater
and i already knew what was coming next
and i'd start laughing out loud yeah
this [ __ ] has the biggest
[ __ ] laugh
it was incredible
yeah we did that when uh i had a friend
who worked at a movie theater um
and so we would get in for free to see
young guns
when young guns came out
we watched that movie probably like 30
times we had it memorized
so much so that we were in there one
that's a tuesday night there's like
eight of us misfits back there just
yelling at the screen and this big biker
dude who was on a date he'd had enough
like he stood up because you shut your
[ __ ] mouth i heard him sitting here
trying to listen
and then we stood up and he he he hit my
buddy
he went attacked eight of us
we probably if we were smart could have
heard it around him or something yeah
he's scary yeah
and it's in the dark
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] but nobody's tripped out on that
stuff man like
yeah you know uh yeah and then
what did i see that
i wanted to see night shift with henry
winkler oh yeah michael yeah in westwood
and me and my buddy ernie sat on the
back row it was sold out
and
it's one of the funniest
at that time funniest everybody in the
theater was laughing roaring with
laughter man yeah
roaring with laughter nobody tripping
and nobody walking out saying like how
can you laugh at this [ __ ] i mean just
yeah what happened to the days where
we'd all be able to sit together
and laugh at [ __ ] and not exactly
i think it's a fear in the dark like
that no one can see they feel safer
sometimes laughing but nobody tripped
though
i didn't get offended as [ __ ] then my
pleasure call me [ __ ] chico pablo
my partner escorted me out we were at a
luncheon at a homicide convention and
the justice of the supreme court was up
there talking i thought he was funny and
i started laughing i couldn't stop
[ __ ] laughing
they're putting a towel over my mouth
come on let's get out of here
but was he funny or he was doing yeah
matter of fact the guy is a professional
boxing uh referee mills
oh the best mill's lame here let's get
out yeah oh yeah get it out oh i know
that guy and he'd go come on let's get
out yeah he was judge mills lane and he
was a badass judge
great referee everybody cool passed away
yeah yeah well there's a few of us still
left
but i mean that stuff like
going to the drive-in
i remember i went to go see uh
uh chichen chung's next movie with my
girlfriend and i took a tape recorder a
cassette recorder because i wanted to
tape
mexican american
and she laughed and i still have the
tape and you can hear me going [ __ ]
trying to get it clean yeah yeah yeah
yeah
she's laughing and i'm like shut the
[ __ ] up
they have to come back tomorrow and i
mean
easy yeah the sex crimes class that i
took that i've talked to you about
before you know this
i asked you to fill him in yeah i asked
the professor this this took uh two
semesters of advanced criminal
investigation pertaining to sex crimes
required more work than i've ever done
yeah and it was a great class this guy
was a great instructor
his credential tell him his credentials
he was a retired fbi agent was head of
the fbi uh over in gallup new mexico
retired was a professor
and counselor up at cal state l.a
and he was just good i learned from him
he taught me how to be a teacher a good
teacher
he used humor
as his vehicle as a vehicle to get his
point across yeah and and he was just so
[ __ ] good i asked him i said do you
mind can i take can we tape your class
he says i don't give a [ __ ] go ahead and
tape it yeah and so i taped it i taped
every one of his classes totally useless
because
all you can do is hear me laughing
and i just i just
blocked everything out because all you
hear is me laughing yeah the guy what
year did you start annoying people with
your lap like were you like five in
school or what year did somebody go
[ __ ]
when i was a kid my mom would beat this
because it's a big level
it's like in families that are poor i
think poor like if you sneeze once
they'll bless you you sneeze twice
they just like shake their head you
sneeze again they're like hey up
[ __ ] sneeze shut eggs that's my
brother man he'll sit right next to me
recliner and be like with food and be
like
ugh
all these noises
i'm like pick one thing man
like what is the [ __ ] experience
like did you get it when i was in boot
camp
the di sergeant eastwood you know you
you watch a movie like the d.i they get
a smoky the bear hat comes he got a new
di in there and he's coming on he's
letting us know he's new and he's the
boss
and he says and i'll i'm just like
you're i'll be your boyfriend your
girlfriend i'll be everything to you the
only difference between me and your
girlfriend is you won't [ __ ] me i'm
gonna [ __ ] you and if you try to [ __ ]
with me i'm just like a match i'll burn
your ass every [ __ ] time
and he said that
and everybody's standing attention were
and he said that and i thought it was
funny
yeah and he comes over to oh maggot he
got right in my face what the [ __ ] he
left him sir i thought that last time
you made about burning my ass
and he said you thought it was funny and
i said sir yes sir he walked behind me
and he kicked me dead in the ass and i
went flying forward oh my god i laughed
on the ground because that had to look
funny you know
i just thought it was funny it wasn't
funny later because then he had me grab
the old rifle and i'm running around the
barracks i will not laugh i should not
laugh
and so then it got tired after but right
then it was funny i've always had the
departmental psychologist
told me i said i'm sorry and she was
she's gone now i can tell you she was a
good-looking lady yeah big kitties
[Laughter]
hey
the streak is so long you can't you know
like joe dimaggio going i'm not gonna
play get your [ __ ] ass in there yeah
so the shrink you know one guy sitting
across from me
and we had been to this cerritos
aircraft disaster oh yeah with the two
plane city you weren't out here yet were
you
and a private plane over the city of
cerritos
he knows all these colliders
and it rained down yeah
killed all 67. my buddy raymond thanks
for coming on
i look around i look over the sky look
at all this disaster out here i said hey
ray
how much time do you think they had from
the time they collided until the time
they hit the ground he looked at me says
well how about enough time for three
eyes and two ideas
yeah that's hilarious see guys
i think they got a good sense of humor i
mean you kind of when they go eat after
you know
so the psychologist is up there talking
and this was before you had to be
politically correct yeah and she's up
there talking i can still see her today
she was wearing red nylons a red dress
and red pumps like the like the wood
again and and she's up there she's
talking so
you know people want to know why we
brought you here together and we found
out from the san diego disaster
that months later days later weeks
months later people started feeling
funny and they didn't know what it was
we found out it was from the disaster
you know their ptsd yeah yeah and so
is that a real thing though
i don't know ptsd
post traumatic stress your [ __ ]
childhood dog get hit by a [ __ ] car
yeah go flying and yeah you know you
have to pretend like you don't know him
[ __ ] him i mean that's traumatic yeah
it's your [ __ ] job yeah it's that's
trauma you guys are like hey man is that
your dog dog my dog
[ __ ] in a [ __ ] tree you know
so i raised my hand she says what is it
and i just looked at her and i went like
this the floor back up i said i think
i'm getting that funny feeling right now
[ __ ]
later we talked i said i'm sorry i can't
stop laughing i'm like she says come and
see me later we'll work on this laughing
problem you have
so it's been your whole yeah yeah it's
been maybe forever i mean it's weird my
brother's this way he laughs at
i was the older brother so i would do
everything i could to you know just beat
the [ __ ] out of this guy yeah yeah and
so i would be wailing on him and he's
just laughing like he he i think he
thought by laughing it's like you're not
you're not fazing me and so that's just
you know he's like he laughs at the
weirdest [ __ ] was it part of his
personality or was it part of the way he
[ __ ] with you i think he's [ __ ]
with me yeah yeah and by the way he got
bigger later in life like he started
like bulking up and doing two a days and
once they learned creatine and all that
[ __ ] and what was your dad what was your
dad like my dad was hilarious my dad uh
well he used to be a cop as well he was
a deputy sheriff uh in catawba county
which is where hickory is
and until he got shot he got shot
almost died bullet hit him in the
stomach at 22 point blank
and it bounced around did the guy did
the guy surprise him or yeah so my dad
was off duty but he heard the call on
the radio like domestic violence thing
and he just knew that he was the closest
one and so he thought well i'm just
going to check on this lady so he goes
to the to the house
guy comes out and there's they just
start swinging he attacked my dad they
start fighting
um
then they start they're chasing like
this guy tried to run my dad's chasing
him he hides behind a wood pile my dad
had flanked him and he pulled his gun
out hit a revolver and he goes all right
it's over raise your hands it's over and
so the guy was on his knees and my dad
was standing and so when he raised his
hands he had a 22. he just went
and one hit him right here no just like
over him yeah like this over his head oh
my gosh just shooting he's like
yeah i just started shooting pow like
that my dad was standing behind him and
it so that they hit him right in the
stomach and uh and one hit and then he
unloaded on that guy and so he killed
that dude but that was after he got a
bullet in his stomach
and he was in the hospital for a while
we were talking before about like
getting addicted to pain pills
he was addicted to morphine for a while
because back then they used morphine and
he was in the hospital for a long time
but did you guys think he was gonna had
to be traumatic for you yeah your dad
yeah well i was a kid so i didn't really
understand what was 22 really caused a
lot of damage in the inside a lot of
people don't know that people want
bigger caliber you know
bigger calories make bigger holes yeah
but they go right through 20 what is a
little 22 uh jam bounces around it
bounces around
damage creates havoc yeah
it's still in the spine they it was so
close to some you know cord they
couldn't get to it and they just left it
in there wow of course that's hickory
hospital 1977
yeah but but you were talking about is
there a lady sweeping the dirt floor
like yeah just into it come on in yeah
like get up walk it off
but he had to wear a colostomy bag he
was messed up for a while then he had
septic shock so they they rewired him
wrong and they had to go back in oh wow
so now he has a uh that might be hickory
though man because like
they rewire
that's right next to fossil bluff
brothers of rice
he's got this scar that looks like a
built-in six-pack now so he's got a gut
like me yeah but he'll his scar is one
here and two across
so you know we go to the one here
takes it off he's like wow i'm [ __ ]
ripped what are you talking about my
grandson has ripped and he says see papa
look at this
this is a six-pack i said son look this
is a cake
yeah but but he had to retire yeah that
well mom was like
no more of this please which was kind of
maybe was that rare where you grew up
that that somebody would fire on a cop
yeah as far as i know yeah i mean i
didn't he don't talk about it much i
mean that was the high thing like you
couldn't shoot that if you killed the
cop man by the way it's going to be shot
my dad my dad returned fire and at that
point other cops had
got there and they all unloaded on this
dude oh man so this guy
i mean i saw pictures polaroids later
you know like
over the years i i said dad tell me that
story again what what happened and then
like you know i get to my teen years i
get a little cocky and he'll slide the
polaroid out so look at all these holes
i told you'd be home at 11 30.
[Laughter]
i'll do it again
but he was a fun he was a fun he was
hilarious he was a funny dude he was the
funny one in his
group of friends and so
as a kid watching my dad make his
friends laugh i'm like wow
they all something would happen and
they'd all look at my dad to see what he
was going to say about right i'm like oh
that's there's some power did he like
did he like comedy did he like yeah yeah
we so it sounds weird now but we grew up
watching bill cosby together sure bill
cosby himself was one of the best
specials i've ever seen in my life it
might be one of the best yeah and so and
that's clean family friendly lean yeah
and we just sat there and watched it and
he was he-hauling at that so he loved
steve martin he loved
snl you know he loved chevy chase he
loved uh
george carlin george collins bill cosby
prior all of it and then so
watching what uh
made my dad
you really bugged him about it because
i guess it was a little pretty traumatic
yeah
you've been shot at right i've been
shooting vietnam i've been shot at in
vietnam i've been shot up by bad guys
here in l.a i've been shot at by cops
here in l.a oh yeah tell us what
challenges came without telling what
happened that was there was a pursuit
going on and but it was one of these
real low level pursuits the guy is only
you know he'd go about 10 miles an hour
and he'd start to pull over and they'd
pull over behind him and then he'd take
off again he was drunk right and so
we're listening to the radio and we're
here it's coming northbound on ford
approaching floral what day was that uh
what i don't know the day that you know
you know he remembers the [ __ ]
i could see where was where was coming
and i said hey they're coming up behind
us right now slow down partner and we
were in an unmarked car
but we both had raid jackets on and so
the car we could see it coming up behind
and it's pulling over
and every time he take off he'd hit a
parked car you know he's hitting cars so
i said okay when he pulls over this time
stay in front of him
just
[ __ ] the car off in case these guys come
out shooting yeah you know wouldn't want
to be in their line of fire so we got
out of the car we blocked them in
a little bit
get out of the car and the guy looks at
me and he starts to put it back in gear
and i'm on the driver's side now on the
trunk by the trunk of my car
the passenger in the chp car
comes out on the book side and now he's
he's pointing at the driver
i'm pointing at the driver this way
and
the driver looks at me he's got a smile
on his face i said [ __ ] you go
and i'll kill you yeah right now you
know i'll dump your ass right here
the driver of the chp car yep he gets
out he sees me playing close i was
playing close games something new back
then yeah he sees me with a gun pointed
essentially he thought i was pointing at
his partner oh on the other side on the
other side got you whoa and he
yells out drop your gun i'm sitting
there saying oh the fucker's got a gun
that i don't know about right yeah yeah
the driver yeah
the book man the the other chp officer
yells back he says
it's okay they're cops
my partner comes around now my partner's
on the now two of us have
guns right there drawing down on the
driver
he says it's okay they're cops
he says drop
your guns
now plural yeah yeah and i look at my
partner i said is this [ __ ] stick
talking to us
and
he said it's okay
the other chippy says
it's okay
they're sheriffs
yeah this guy responds
i don't know who they are
whoa drop your guns oh yeah so i said i
threw my gun it was a county gun
my partner was really pissed because it
was his personal gun
he threw it on the ground and then the
guy goes
whoa whoa and he shoots
and both of us jump on the other side of
the car and i told my partner i said
okay [ __ ] him don't just stay down i got
another gun right here i pulled another
gun out yeah i said if he goes the cab
again i'll dump it and i was i was gonna
dump his ass
by this time the gang members had heard
all the sirens you know the pursuit was
going we're now stopped they're on the
streets they're watching they know
what's going on and they're going
they're seeing cops shoot cops they
gotta be [ __ ] happy
the other chp officer starts yelling you
stupid [ __ ] and i mean he's
going off on him
this guy now realizes what he's done
yeah and he's coming over he's begging
for forgiveness are you trying to hit
you or no yeah oh [ __ ] he just missed
him
and he says you know i'm so sorry i'm
sorry
[ __ ] you're sorry right now you better
take care those gang members are going
to lynch your suspect right now
you better attend to him you take care
of him yeah we're not hit we'll deal
with this after
as he shot at us wow other cops were
coming up from the sheriff's department
they were coming up they hear the
gunshot go off now they're asking
for
more assistance shots fired
they don't realize that it was the cop
right their own started us
everything's okay code four is a you put
up four fingers and i'm saying it is
code four and the other guy yells on the
radio negative code four shots fired
continue to respond
and i the radio dispatcher said i've got
one unit saying it's code four okay now
they're gonna say more units
and i just told them
put the microphone down yeah
and i said you're just starting stirring
[ __ ] up yeah i said you see like a young
younger dude just the guy that fire
happy the the guy that fired this was
his 12th day on the streets right he had
never been out there
and
his sergeant and writing it up said
had he heard had a 10-ton tr mack truck
come by and sounded his horn he never
would have hurt
he just went into vapor lock and he
blamed it on up in sacramento he says
they train these guys and they think
you're going to east l.a and it was the
worst place in the world to go to
dangerous
so all he could think of was danger
didn't
it was it no no and and it and he he
ended up getting fired yeah he ended up
getting fired so he took a shot at you
and he just missed he missed you so
after all that happened did you ever
pull him aside later go have lunch with
him no no no no no
let's talk about this
yeah because number one
i knew he couldn't be out on the streets
anymore because
next time he's going to be hesitant and
somebody might get hurt because of his
lack
of ability to take care of and
it's too dangerous right now to be out
on the streets
he went ahead they fired him and he
filed an appeal i had to go to his
attorney said i'm sorry to have to put
you through this we try to tell him
don't do this it's going to be
embarrassing
and he did it anyway he lost and last i
heard he was working for the railroad
you know he was up in the barstow area
oh no okay
these chicken vaccine cards and
restaurants
yeah right yeah so
you know
no
i i it's weird growing up with that i i
was like respecting guns all right your
dad had probably taught you guys how to
shoot guns yeah actually that same gun
he used to kill that dude uh he actually
shot his own his bed one time with it
trying to show me guns
it went off in the house he did and
that's loud as hell when a gun goes off
indoors you can't hear for a good 10
seconds probably your ears his ears are
ringing
anyway he's like this is what he did
he's like all right i'll show you what
this is what i do every day before i
leave
make sure
i make sure the safety is on
and then i point it at the bed and i
pull the trigger just to make sure that
it's on and if it's not on then all i
did was shoot the bed see it just like
this
and he had already had it on and he
turned it off oh yeah yeah yeah so he
just he [ __ ] up [ __ ] in his pants
shut the bed
i was not a gun dude i didn't hunt
i didn't i didn't really i don't care
about fishing i mean that's what i do
country-ish i'm kind of like that black
is for red country is yeah a little bit
but not real that's awesome
like you know you bob evans or are you
cracker barrel
i like both but i'm gonna go crack a
barrel yeah i like their hash browns i
like their chicken their chicken's great
too yeah yeah who started that the clan
no
i think they think they did that
that's where we secretly uh uh but
it's pretty good you can't get anything
healthy in there no
we
was asking like what kind of oil and
that lady says i don't know if you know
where you're at son you're in cracker
barrel like we know what kind of oil we
don't know what the oil
you gotta squeak somewhere
they they get they get after it man yeah
and by the way have you ever eaten at a
cracker barrel uh
like at night
it's always during the daytime cracker
barrel yeah it's always during the day
but don't go at night it's that it's a
weird shift
um
all i smelled was bad fish when i went
there at night one time i was like this
is depressing i don't know what
yeah they got the gift shop which is
kind of nice uh but being in there
you know and you're smelling this nasty
fish and and uh they're slow it's a
different shift to people yeah they're
in the daytime they're they're up
they're ready to roll the old grease
yeah all the old oil has been
cooking all day long but that place uh
it's grown it's not diminished in in
size it's everywhere yeah that's
everywhere unfortunately the closest one
around here is off the 15. oh really
yeah up there by victorville
but bob evans is good too bob evans is
great anything in the bob evans i mean
almost anything you can get a cracker
good good sausages
biscuits are different bob evans still
now oh really sausage is great right
yeah yeah great yeah the jacksonville
comedy zone uh
they right next to it is the bob evans
so i know every time i go there that's
at least three times i'm gonna be in bob
yeah yeah i get three different meals
you know because they have everything
the same thing just go to your go-to's
well my goats i like breakfast there
their breakfast is great um what's the
glitches pancakes yeah and or just a
just a basic you know blt you know
something simple you're a country
[Laughter]
blt yeah breakfast was always my
favorite me too i don't care where i'm
at i'm in vegas
that's all i ever used to eat yeah
what's your bread what's your breakfast
what's your go-to breakfast
hashbrowns eggs
and sausage patties or link
uh patties
patties or chocolates or chicken fried
steak and eggs sourdough toast
chicken fried turkey remember they used
to butter
for you and come down and be dripping
and butter yeah
and you go [ __ ] hey leave that now
they tell you like the brotherhood's on
the side or don't do it yeah they had a
paint brush they would put the butter on
with a [ __ ] paintbrush
some places when i was out here those
are the good old days [ __ ] put that
thing in there yeah yeah a little mist
taste
there are some places out here that
annoyed me with the breakfast because
you'd get there and you'd want like you
know butter for your toast and they
bring you this butter and it's cold and
stiff and i'm like
i'm trying to spread this on my toast
that's breaking the bread's falling
apart you're going to let this stuff sit
out for a while it's like trying to
spread mascara
[ __ ] things curling up
like a crayon i remember in vegas one
time i was eating breakfast with another
couple
nice guy and
and we're sitting there
and he's looking at me
and he sees me like this
and he's starting to eat and he says oh
excuse me i'm sorry gil
i made the sign of the cross you start
praying i look at him i said hey don't
get that excited brother i'm just trying
to soften up my butter
that's hilarious yeah
that's funny i mean you know and people
are so uh
so [ __ ] against like whole milk right
or i mean everybody that drank
buttermilk is dead pretty much
i mean
i haven't seen buttermilk anywhere a
long time people mad i this dude
would come out with a [ __ ] glass of
buttermilk
and he would be like what you guys doing
today and he would drink it and it's
just like
[Music]
yeah that used to be like part of the
diet was like a glass of milk like you
just drink and you milk as your pet
without butter
buttermilk buttermilk special it was
like [ __ ] beige
yeah it looked like it looked like the
milk after you ate all the cereal yeah
yeah yeah
look dude i think there's some cornbread
in this milk what's that that's a little
bit more drinks yeah christmas time
though
eggnog eggnog with lumps in it that's
what it looked like yeah yeah it's thick
uh just put that in your coffee maybe
you think it makes it
do you think it oh what time this dude
dude came to my house we're in the
desert and hadn't been in the desert a
long time so he got he gets up early
he's in there he's got a cup of coffee
and he's eating like some biscuits you
know biscotti and i get up and i go
where did you find the the milk and he
goes all the whipped cream
i'll put the whipped cream in there and
you know stir it i go where did you get
those
those crackers and he goes they're in
there man the biscottis they were the
[ __ ] pumpkin snacks for the dog
he was [ __ ] dipping them in the
coffee i go dude those are the [ __ ]
dog snacks
and he's like what oh well
he's sitting there with his legs crossed
dipping it in the [ __ ] thing
a little bit [ __ ] like that happened
just he they're just sitting there with
a plate of them
my brother went down he was eating uh
like kentucky fried chicken and my
brother hates the he's a health nut so
he takes the skin off right so he's
taking the skin off which is the best
part really yeah you don't really want
anybody to see you eat the skin in
public
oh dude he was taking the skit off and
then just like after his mouth and like
pulling it and putting on the side of
the plate and my dad walks over he's
like oh you're not gonna eat that
jason's like no after he'd been in his
mouth and just started
and he didn't stop him they let him eat
all of it that was all my mouth
last year for thanksgiving my grandson
learned you know when i said hey there's
no turkey skin left over and he said
well your grandson took it all he said
well i didn't know you like this stuff
papa
i said now eat it all now covered you
know you didn't leave me any
between myself my granddaughter and him
we'll scarf it all up that's the best
part yes is it bad for you though with
the skin yeah yeah i think it is but
it's just got all like fat
every five years they change stuff
turns out chicken skin's good for you
you know we'll hear that about five do
you ever been to arthur bryant's in
kansas city at that barbecue place
brian you know they're over there big uh
arthur bryant so there's another place
over there okay so we were in kansas
city i went for the the race and nascar
race and we go we got to go to arthur
bryant so we go in there all
african-american guys they see me
and then i call me over and i go in the
back and i look in the trash can and
they're
cutting the ends off and throwing them
in the trash and i said
the [ __ ] are you guys doing i go in
there and start eating the ends out of
the trash
the ends of the of the of the roast the
the oh okay the brisket after they had
cooked it they were just good and nobody
ate the ants
and i said what do you mean nobody eats
the ends no that's why down there with
the [ __ ] bare-handed [ __ ] eating
out of the oven that's that's a bit bad
i bet it was delicious it's [ __ ] the
best because kansas city knows how to
make barbecue for sure i haven't been to
that one nobody ate the ends like the
ends of the bread i eat yeah the coral
they would call it the heel
heel the heel yeah uh i eat that
yeah you know you get a you grab peanut
butter and jelly sandwich the top looks
good you have the [ __ ] hand on the
other side
your first bite is like you're like
yeah no i never did like the end matter
of fact when i was a kid i would even
cut the edge of the bread off i didn't i
didn't like oh you don't like the crust
either yeah
now i do but then i didn't i went to i'd
go to this donor place right there in
burbank and uh saturday morning
this latino guy skinny dude riding a
bike in the bike closed tends to be
closed
and his girlfriend are in there and oh
yeah they go can we help he goes no we
go for bike rides we just come in and
smell the donuts
oh my god what the [ __ ] are you kidding
me
that's like a hate crime
and i was like
that was kind of breeding human [ __ ] out
of here yeah you're just coming to smell
like just going to smell they go for a
ride they get off they go in there and
smell the donuts and and take off again
they smell my coolo
smell each other it's cool
but but do you think it makes a
difference uh do you think it makes a
difference ultimately
whether you had blue cheese or
[ __ ] lemon juice on your salad
you mean in life yeah uh uh how many
days does i'm not gonna let that i'll
i'm not gonna change my eating pattern i
mean how many days do you get right more
that's what i'm saying like you want an
extra week at the end when you're
paralyzed you know what that
[ __ ] gets hit by a car on the
bike i'll get some donuts and throw it
in the [ __ ] coffin with them you can
[ __ ] smell of a eternity in there
betty white
yes she just died
a couple of weeks before her before her
100th birthday and every day she had
hot dogs hot dog
vodka
every day so
now take away that hot dog in the vodka
how many more
days did she have left at the end did
you ever meet betty white no i never had
never met did you meet her no i've never
met her i would have never had the you
know the thing about betty white i would
say
is that
these are people that have been around
our whole lives sure like there wasn't a
time when you were watching password
or mary tyler moore
or which she was [ __ ] amazing in mary
tyler moore right or i don't really kind
of remember other than what adam london
hosted password they were the golden
girls golden girls so in your life
she's always been around sure and for
her to be gone it's big because
it's like somebody that's always been in
your life my son it was like a personal
friend passed away
when she when she did he he loved her
and he followed the golden girls for
forever you know through reruns he loved
great man
has a bad word to say about her
from what i hear is like the nicest
person and always delivered all showed
up on time you know did did she shave
dogs funny
and wasn't afraid to come out
with adult uh stuff yeah yeah yeah she
she was like she could go toe-to-toe it
was a sport yeah
you know lucy was a little feisty
[ __ ] like lucy was mean and [ __ ]
yeah you know
when lucy was in
poor health at cedars when i was going
over through my procedures the girl that
was the
mri technician would say you know hold
your breath and i'll tell you when to
let go and try to make a joke with lucy
and lucy goes i'll do the jokes if you
don't mind
and it was a feisty [ __ ] [ __ ]
meaning and [ __ ] in there but toward the
end of her life so you got to meet lucy
i didn't mean lucy but i met betty white
yeah yeah and betty white was on my talk
show and i said you know you're more
busy now than you've ever been and she
was like yo i'm such a horror i can't
say no
ad-lib
and i remember when she came out she had
the
the shoes the comfortable shoes with the
nylon seam at her toe like your
grandmother wears
and the same kind of naugahyde brown
with the with the strap around the ankle
oh wow she had like a tiger top like my
grandmother and when i hugged her she
smelled old she was 90.
and i remember thinking
you smell like my grandmother yeah but
hugging her and she was
like the old lady perfume yeah and she
was great man that's great
i think they they showed that clip
uh the one you just talked about is i'm
a [ __ ] i think they said
they showed that clip on uh
i don't know on the internet because i
remember seeing it yeah i mean great man
i don't know the other guy uh george
allen you know [ __ ] george allen he
used to do a
one-man show there towards him when he
was getting old the football coach no no
no george burns excuse me george burns
yeah yeah
george yeah
yeah george burns and when he did his
one-man show
they asked him you know hey uh what do
your doctors say about you drinking
still and smoking
and because it's been said you have
uh a shot of scotch and you have a cigar
every day
he says that's very true he says but as
far as my doctors he says which one most
of my doctors are dead
yeah i beat him yeah yeah i lived as
well i was watching a golf tournament in
lake tahoe in the
late 70s or something you know
and and the two announcers were talking
about seeing george burns
in his 90s doing a show at midnight oh
wow and they go imagine a guy in his
early 90s is up at midnight and the guy
goes
he sleeps 23 hours a day
he's only up that one hour he's up at 11
30. he goes to bed at 1 15. he's back to
sleep sleeps all day i remember them
saying that thinking [ __ ] yeah yeah he's
doing that now i'm 49.
one hour but but
those guys were
special man like i saw milton berle yeah
in 1988 at an abandoned beverly hills
and some guy went up there and and
talked about material or something and
said mountain borough probably took that
and milton berle stood up in a room with
3 000 people and just did that face he
would do like
and everybody started laughing didn't
say a word and just stood up and made
that face and i thought that
is [ __ ] brilliant man he had the
tuxedo yeah he looked like a you know
you look like
like like the hilton
the guy you know yeah amazing would you
ever go to the friars club stuff yeah
yeah i never i never got into that what
i kind of wanted to guys they had one in
l.a and they they [ __ ] tore down okay
i had one of my wrap parties for my show
at the friars club i'm a friar in new
york yeah
yeah cause jeff ross always did the
roast at the comedy store the best those
were the i i love watching yeah i don't
make me nervous i like watching them
but the times i've been on it i'm just
like i'm scared shitless
it's something where you have to keep
your senses up on yeah
yeah and you're like well you have a
joke who did you do who did you do
i roasted uh a nascar driver uh denny
hamlin
uh and i roasted uh well lavelle
crawford um i won uh
season five of last comic standing and
so it was between me and lavelle and
this other guy jerry d so we all had to
do a roast of each other with other
comedians out there but it's still jeff
ross of course was there yeah you know
the master at the stuff and you know and
i mean he just stopped he was doing
jokes and i'm sitting on this little
like this little throne you know because
i'm the one getting roasted or whatever
and he just
he stopped the middle of the joke and
turned around looked at me goes god
you're ugly
like that and then just kept going i was
like
yeah and the way yeah that's just an
insult
there's no punch line you [ __ ]
so they always make me nervous that
stuff is uh
that's the spirit but i like watching it
from afar you know it's a little bit
interesting to be it's almost like being
in a battle royal yeah in wrestling like
your senses have to be up oh yeah and
you have to be listening
and you got to take your
you got to take your shots and the best
way to take is just laugh at it even if
it pisses you off yeah just laugh
because it never shows a sign of
weakness yeah it doesn't look like that
never let them know that they get to you
like when they roasted trump uh at the
uh was it the inauguration thing or
whatever no no it's some ball they
always do
seth meyers was broke
making jokes about him the
correspondence dinner yeah that's what
it was and they just had a camera on
trump and he was not digging it man no
you gotta laugh it off it made him look
really stupid you know when obama was
was going in on him that's right that
made him decide to run for president
yeah
yeah that's a great question that's
right clip great because he would he's
like i got one thing you'll never have
for i'm one thing you'll never you're
just the president of the united states
and then they like curb your enthusiasm
i mean obama could obama was a
he had good timing he's funny oh yeah
great great speaker obviously and great
he goes you know that guy talked to
everybody it's like yeah he went in
there some of his correspondence stuff
about trump's decision whether
meatloaf or the guy from nsync like he
goes it's those kind of decisions he has
to make
that keep me up every night like he went
in
he went in i just wonder what he would
really how how loose
because i agree with you he was good he
was quick
how how much better he'd have been if he
didn't have to respond if he didn't have
to answer to his wife when he you know
to me it looked like she
he was a little hesitant to say stuff
that might be the michelle yeah
he'd been better off i'm not being a
divorce don't write in letters yeah i
mean it's just like i'd take it he'd
have been better
if you didn't have the answer i think
it's better always maybe when your wife
isn't around depending on
i don't know
oh yeah
i uh played golf with o.j
oh after oh i don't think i've ever told
this story oh my god
o.j i hear oj's playing at a handsome
damn
with some dudes that i know dave dave uh
and this guy
some chicano dudes out there and o.j is
out at noahwood and we're playing
norwood and i see him you know
and the first time i saw him was that
handsome damn like now he's playing
public courses like la public horses
right
and
i'm hitting balls and i look over and
he's walking up
with the way he walks you know his bad
pigeon toad yeah and he sticks his hand
in where my golf balls are and pulls out
like 10 golf balls and doesn't say
may i or do you mind
and then he looks at me goes you're
pretty hard on me and i said
i said i was
and he goes yeah
but he goes not like uh jay leno
or letterman and then he says you know
those [ __ ] yeah and i remember
he said fodder
like my life is spotter yeah for them
yeah yeah and then
and i mean hand to god man
i'm playing with with him
and
on 18 he comes across it and yanks it
and he goes did it anybody see where
that went
and one guy goes i think it's playable
juice and i said look at it this way
you're not in jail
which means you can still hit the ball
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah he's like i sliced it and
like you're playing skins
this is going to get out there playing
skins
and then somebody
allegedly handed them some money and ah
man and said
do you have to give half of this to fred
goldman um
[Laughter]
hey bottom line that's good i mean
that's gonna be weird but i mean to be
and you know my wife found out and
this [ __ ] at this party came up
to me and goes i can't believe you
played golf without your [ __ ] wife
was right there uh but he stole balls
from me we went around he was a big
[ __ ] i stole my [ __ ]
gunpowder
and we went in the car round and round
man
and i said
she was crying
and i said listen and i'm a comedian
like i do that [ __ ] for the experience
for the for saying
that i did it not too because i
either choose
one thing or the other but as a comedian
i mean i have that story now as opposed
to right i could have but you mean you
didn't i did right because i wanted the
[ __ ] story i'm the one that said you
playing golf it's not gonna change
anything this [ __ ] had a
hawaiian tropic fanny pack that still
had numbers of [ __ ] models and [ __ ]
they had some lollipops in there [ __ ]
ones and ones
and i said hey juice you ever think
you'd end up playing a city course with
some mexicans he goes never not even
thought never
he said he was at riviera he didn't even
did never
hey jews you ever think you'd end up
playing with messier than a city course
in l.a never
no he didn't hesitate didn't hesitate
another big joke at that time during
that during that time was the bottom
line
fourth and short i'd still give juice
the ball
he's finally free
yeah yeah he's out now like i mean how
long has he been out
but he's free like he's out of probation
everything yeah like he's out out we we
uh he wanted to come and see me at the
laugh factory on like on the weekend i
was doing like it was in the 90s yeah
and uh he said to me he said i'd love to
go and check you out and i said yeah and
he had this assistant kathy and he goes
kathy will call you and we'll arrange it
like we'll call over there he goes
because sometimes
he says sometimes i have a problem yeah
and i don't think that there's gonna be
a problem
[ __ ] jamie's like man don't bring him
here
the oj man
brother don't bring the oj here man
you know the owner of the left back
israeli yes
don't bring the o.j to my club man
please and i i had i had to tell him
that it was a no-go okay wow were you
worried about his reaction at all
right how did he handle that
i [ __ ] run away from that
[ __ ] hardly moved
it was like the tin man when he [ __ ]
got all seized up he had the worst swing
yeah
and you know i invited we were
can we we got to take we were at
knollwood and down at uh
down over there we used to get some
[ __ ] panama there and sepulveda and
rinaldi about where lenny bruce is
buried on my grandmother or grandfather
uh there's a place called president in
mission hills
and they have a great uh bar in there
and i asked him i said juice let's go to
president the man it's like damn you're
going to get on the freeway it's right
over the overpass and he said no he said
i can't
really
he said if i go in there
and he
and he was
yeah it's on like he's back but watching
him play golf and standing there while
he's putting the ball in the ground and
swinging with that
horrible [ __ ] swing
terrible swing
but to know that that is the most
infamous person oh yeah in the whole
world crazy and he's right there in
front of you
it's so weird i mean so is his swing
worse than charles barkley's swing
you seen charles barkley's swing i've
heard he's getting better charles
barkley was a good golfer yeah but he
just said somebody told him
at the bob hope in the desert
chuck
you come down too fast from the top you
got to let you got to pause and then
bring it down [ __ ] them up [ __ ] him up
because he pauses
so we're playing in atlanta
and barclay's gonna hit on the first tee
and everybody stops and he goes i don't
know what y'all think you're gonna see
he takes it back he stops he swings he
[ __ ] knicks the ball it goes between
his legs
and [ __ ] passes us we're he's hitting
the ball over here yeah we're over here
the [ __ ] ball it almost goes in the
[ __ ] pro shop
it goes between his legs it passes us
we're not even in the way of the ball
he [ __ ] nicked it and went between
his legs he couldn't do that again if he
tried and you [ __ ] couldn't do it
again
and like the ball was like i'm going in
the pro shop guys the [ __ ] check out
and the [ __ ] ball almost went inside
now
i can't swing either i uh i've tried
i love golf i mean i i wish i was good
at it because i all my friends play and
i'm just like i wish you were good at it
too you could play my [ __ ] tournament
i'd love to that's the first question i
always ask people when i meet him george
asked me he invited me to go out golfing
yeah and i said i'll turn into the
comedian because all you do is tell him
what it was like
tell him what it was like well the
tournament was great yeah it was i was
nervous
i really i'm not i don't get i don't get
nervous about much
[ __ ] you've been shot at why
would you be here
and that day that i was leaving my house
uh i told the wife i said i'm really
nervous you know going down to the you
know i'm not used to being around a
bunch of celebrities i don't golf and
they had already scared the [ __ ] out of
me because yeah this place that he plays
that you know you have dress code yeah
you know i mean so i had to go out and
buy me dress code clothes to be on the
right
and plus
yes he's my friend but i didn't want to
be a pain in his ass you know hey you
gotta
you gotta do your tournament yeah and he
said no come on ed they treated me great
it was so much fun uh it was a day that
i'll never forget who did you see there
who who did you uh d.l ugly cedric the
entertainer i'll never forget dale hugh
because he treated me so good
he was so good making sure everything
was right uh
god the
[ __ ] i just watched this movie he told
you that he didn't he didn't like cops
he said i gotta tell you something i i
gotta be honest with you and i said okay
what is it
and he says uh i don't like most cops
and i said okay yeah
that's duly noted
one shot at me [ __ ] i get it
yeah
matter of fact i'm gonna be brutally
honest i hate all you [ __ ] i
said
okay that's okay too
and he said but you're different you
know and he just said you're different
man you you i've never seen a cop talk
like you you act like you yeah he said
and i listened to the thing with you and
he does get thing going and i listen to
george all the time
he says you just have this chemistry
going it's great and george said you've
never done it since and that it's great
and all day long
george lopez the man that he is and
hosts the celebrity golf tournament
we're one of three carts that don't have
a [ __ ] roof over there yeah yeah so
everybody on the hat it's like drinking
wholemeal [ __ ] it the sun
so that that was it so hugely all day
long kept saying guilt don't forget
hydrate
hydrate relax you know dude and i wasn't
golfing i'm just riding around the golf
cart with him yeah and so he really
treated me joe pesci
uh yeah oh yeah
how did you play that day i didn't play
all i did was set my fat ass in the car
ride around with george what did your
passion tell you joe pesci was just a
good guy he's a funny guy what you see
joe pesci on the screen was joe pesci
live i love that you know he was just uh
the way he talks the way he acts and the
thing that i'll never forget is somebody
wanted to take we stopped at one hole
they were giving booze away there
and uh publishers comes up with mr pesci
there's a youngster in the back and the
next fortune that'd like to take a
picture with you if you have time yeah
let's go take the picture right now and
he walked back there and come back
he goes like this put his arm around
they're setting up for the picture and
and joe pesci says hey
he said i said i take the picture get
your [ __ ] arm off
right yeah
funny like so joe pesci he don't like to
be grand manhattan doesn't play around
yeah okay so i had a guy
that was the biggest
manufacturer of like notions lotion
vitamins stuart
uh an annoy you know how annoying this
dude is trump
told me that that's the most annoying
person he's met
so [ __ ] this is the dude that annoys
trump imagine how [ __ ] annoying you
gotta be when trump goes that guy's the
most annoying [ __ ] guy i've ever met
so he's orange he's got his [ __ ] hair
back he's orange and he's loud and he's
got pictures of you know stuff he's
already bringing his camera out and he's
calling [ __ ] joe
pesky oh
and right around the putting green he's
like pesky the whole day
pesky this and joe goes hey listen
maybe you don't know
because maybe nobody told you but it's
not pesky [ __ ] it's pitch and he
goes hey take it easy pesky i'm just
busting the clothes
i don't know if you're busting my balls
you [ __ ] orange [ __ ]
and he goes i have melanoma and he goes
good i hope you die you
[ __ ] ah
[ __ ]
he's gonna put him in a trunk and stab
him [ __ ] [ __ ] good fellas and that
dude was like all of a sudden he's like
[ __ ] pouting i said hey stewart
he walked right into show him some
[ __ ] respect man yeah you can't bust
balls to strangers i feel like you
that's a rite of pa you have to know
somebody for a little bit to start
busting balls you know he does [ __ ] for
me that he would not normally do man
ever i just because it's just of years
of 17 years of knowing each other
yeah yeah but
i'm going to tell you guys a story that
i told jim brewer i think he told howard
sterling supposedly we'll probably
probably won't make it to the podcast
but he did for us
so billy andrade is a golfer he's
playing in the he's playing i'll tell
you a couple let me tell you one story
there's a bit before that one so yeah
yeah joe pesci and jack nicholson go to
the laker game they're working on a
movie and chicks come up to jack jack's
got his glasses on he's got the smile
and whenever he was at the laker game
and he had his glasses those
rose-colored glasses and women would
come up they would show the women on the
thing try to get close to jack objects
with big tits everybody's laughing and
[ __ ] and pesci's right there with his
hat
and uh they go home they go to the game
together they go back to peshe's uh to
jack nicholson's house in beverly in bel
air and they go in and uh and joe's like
i'm getting that [ __ ] drink this
[ __ ] tells me i gotta leave and
i said what he goes what he goes he
comes up to him he goes
i'm gonna have to ask him
and he goes what a [ __ ]
i'm gonna have to ask you to leave
and he goes because why i have a young
lady that's coming over
and he goes when young lady you [ __ ]
goes the young lady from the laker again
i gotta go upstairs and make myself
presentable
and jopez she goes yeah [ __ ] she don't
give a [ __ ] she's what jack nichols said
she don't give a [ __ ] about you she's
here to [ __ ] jack nicholson nonetheless
and then there you go joe pressure goes
hey jack you ever use my aggro and he
goes only when i'm outnumbered
oh that's good [ __ ] swear to god
so
billy andre
is playing at he's a he this is the 90s
so so jack was a member of lakeside joe
still there jack left which is
sad to me because his locker was around
mine and
[ __ ] jack was
one day i'm playing in the afternoon
because when i was doing when the show
was on i would go over there in
afternoon a ball comes flying over my
head guess who's in a cart with no top
jack nicholson is completely [ __ ] wet
his hair is back like fingered back
sweaty [ __ ] coke rings
and coke on his [ __ ] chest and he's
driving and a ball comes over my head
and he goes george we're going to play
through him
i said [ __ ] go ahead man
go ahead go ahead jack yeah and i look
up and they're [ __ ] walking across
you the carts going over the [ __ ]
green shit's not supposed to do and i
look up and they're gone like i said
it's almost like the [ __ ]
abandoned buildings like the guys with a
[ __ ] knife he's gone
there's no way those [ __ ] could
have disappeared that bad i hit a
[ __ ] ball and look they're gone oh
[ __ ] so so so
that's good so billy [ __ ] yeah makes you
[ __ ] disappear
yeah [ __ ] look up like [ __ ] grease
the [ __ ] head takes off at the end
so so so
billy andrade
and pastor are friends so so you know
you play
thursday friday if you don't make the
cut you're you're free for the weekend
and billy goes hey man if i don't make
the cut i'll come down he goes yeah
[ __ ]
and jack and i are playing in the
morning [ __ ] don't make the [ __ ]
come out there and play the [ __ ] back
now
you know so so billy andrew gets there
he's got his buick bag professional he's
got his hat looks like a pro and he says
uh can we help you sorry because i'm hit
play with the mr pesce he goes oh mr
president nicholson are
are on the eighth t eighth green putting
take the card and meet him on the 19.
so he's there they they're there become
billy comes around and he pulls up along
uh joe and he sees him and joe's like
you know because you know guys are
hitting and jack's up there and jack
just [ __ ] jax
was never really good but it was cool
that he played and the ball and he just
[ __ ] struggling the whole day
and billy goes i think i can give jack a
tip and he's like yeah go ahead and tell
him [ __ ] you know he's playing
like [ __ ] he's getting [ __ ]
everywhere and and and he so so billy
doesn't introduce himself
and he walks up to jack and he goes hey
jack
i think i can give you a tip and jack
has been playing [ __ ] bad
nine holes he goes yeah yeah yeah
everybody's got a tip for jack
and he goes well i got a tip for you
buddy you can take that tip and shove it
up your [ __ ] ass
so i mean he's only been at the course
five minutes yeah and his [ __ ] eyes
are like this he goes back and sits down
and pets he goes what did he say he goes
nothing and he goes no what did he say
to you because he told me to take my tip
and shove it up shove it up my ass and
peshe jumps out of the car and he goes
hey i'm [ __ ] that's my friend
i don't give a [ __ ] who it is
and he's like you [ __ ] apologize i'm
not apologizing for [ __ ] and you and
your friend can go [ __ ]
and they're [ __ ] billy henry's like
what the [ __ ] so now you got joe pesci
and [ __ ] jack nicholson [ __ ]
toe-to-toe
i don't give a [ __ ] who it is
you show some [ __ ] respect to my
family yeah [ __ ] priv
[ __ ] you and your friend
and at the [ __ ] after the ninth hole
[ __ ] jack left man he he [ __ ] left
god that would be a i told
and he goes you know how george is such
a great storyteller how he's like yeah
one of the best i'm not one of the best
[ __ ] star i don't [ __ ] have any
stories and he [ __ ] tells my phone's
[ __ ] blowing up every construction
worker is like a [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is that
he did that story he loved him the golf
tournament did he he did yeah he told
the story no no
[ __ ] press
he was
being egged on by
george
you know what i always get him to try to
tell like i used to try to finesse and
now he'll be like hey [ __ ] i
said joe tell them about the come on
take it easy let me [ __ ] talk
he's the best i love that dude man i
would if i were you i would play golf
just to go and be able to present
because isn't it special to see a dude
like that yes like a [ __ ] academy
award winner yes in the in his [ __ ]
element with his hat
and his thing like i sent him i sent him
a christmas present
and i didn't i didn't you know i love
him man i i think he's great and
when he sends a message that's like
heartfelt
he's like thank you so much for the
gorgeous sweater you should have but i
thank you thank you thank you i hope you
have a very merry christmas and a happy
new year i'm off to vegas either today
or tomorrow to see my daughter uh
tiffany i hope to see you soon not a
[ __ ] in there
heartfelt sweet
man every year we drink [ __ ] martinis
that's a [ __ ] icon as you know it was
wow
could you imagine if a camera crew just
followed around
uh jack nicholson and joe pesci i would
watch that it's a t-shirt
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you you [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh that's awesome can you imagine how i
feel i mean being around these guys
right yeah just you just sit back and
observe right i mean god of mine and you
know truvino's like how's my friend joe
i said joe's looking great man i talked
to trevino lee tremino's like one of my
and we were talking about golf like you
know since he did that thing with tiger
and the sun like he's got all these
offers because they he goes people no i
can still hit a gulp as 82. and i said
to him i said uh hey man in your prime
who could [ __ ] beat you he said coors
[Laughter]
he goes nobody could beat me only miss
course that's what he said [ __ ]
chords
i'd come out there man the only thing
i'd beat myself like i'd get too [ __ ]
hammered and not play well
play good but they get me man did you
ever meet john daly oh yeah because he i
don't think coors would stop that guy i
think that helps him like he's that like
right he would just get drink a 18 pack
and still like drive the wheel
we're at the bob hope that's a big guy i
play i play golf i've known him forever
big bubba rednecky kind of a guy right
we used to go play a lot we used to go
meet at las casuelas after
after
playing golf
uh at 111 and washington
and it became a thing where
most of the celebrities went there
but then daley shows up
and i kid you not
this [ __ ] had
double shots of [ __ ] crown royal
double shots i'll show you some pictures
of
double shots and he's [ __ ] talking
and he's cool
laughing
and and now girls are there like hot
chicks are there
and uh
he you know and he's just [ __ ] it i
mean he's still i mean he's just a
carton of cigarettes he's drinking and
the one so
he's drinking the a double [ __ ] crown
and remember you know when a plane takes
off you can see the [ __ ] ripples of
of the heat coming yeah from the back of
the [ __ ] engine it's like the air is
waving yeah i was sitting next to him
and he'd drink the shot and he'd go
[ __ ] air would come out and it would
[ __ ] ripple
it would [ __ ] it like a [ __ ] jet was
going to take up he's drinking jet fuel
and i would be like holy [ __ ] and he's
[ __ ] drinking [ __ ] 18 and i get up
and i go to the [ __ ] waitress and i
said listen
don't give them anymore like put a
little bit of [ __ ] crown but put like
coke in there and the lady goes nothing
is george we know how to do it we deal
with people all that time
[ __ ] brings it he takes a shot he
goes georgie it goes like [ __ ] the
ken bay mutombo
georgie
there's all these hot [ __ ] chicks
there and he goes
hey girls
you ever had your [ __ ] eaten [ __ ]
good and i'm like all right
i said john
we're cool man no no georgie george you
relax
hot ladies and they're like this like
no have you ever had your [ __ ] like
really eaten
and i like john georgie georgie give me
one
give me one of those chips right there
you give him a [ __ ] basket of
tortilla chips and he dips it in the
water
and he goes girl has you ever had
anybody eat your [ __ ] like this and he
takes the chip
and puts it in his lip and he goes
and this [ __ ] [ __ ] is [ __ ] waving
like
francis scott key when he wrote that
star spangled better than that
that [ __ ] chip didn't break it
[ __ ] rippled it made it sound like
and those [ __ ] girls one girl got up
and left and the other four were like
i've never seen anything [ __ ] like it
oh my god i've never seen anything like
it
and and that guy
came to my house rented a house
and
we were watching because you know it's
on the golf channel all week
and they do like that 19th hole grey
goose 19 and they're talking about john
daly and he's in the kitchen
the kitchen was open so it's like he's
looking right there with his arms
falling we just come from the restaurant
and he's [ __ ] up
and they're talking about how he has to
play and how he owes so much money and
how he's been divorced so many times and
how his [ __ ] life is a mess
right he [ __ ] goes off and starts
yelling at the [ __ ] tv man like
yeah something
if he'd have been an actor he might have
won an academy award really you
[ __ ] don't know a [ __ ] thing
about my [ __ ] life you [ __ ] sit
there and you [ __ ] point your [ __ ]
thing you know what it's [ __ ] like to
[ __ ] i mean
and we were just like [ __ ] like yeah
we need to [ __ ] shoot this
[ __ ]
i love that dude his saving grace of why
he's not dead yeah is because when he
gets drunk he's not a mean drunk right
yeah he's a lovable guy yeah if he's if
he'd have been a mean drunk somebody
would have shot him already oh right
well he's like he's like
yeah but not not mean yeah so and he's
functioning too like he can he can
actually play well
and be [ __ ] up right so
we're playing that was wednesday
wednesday thursday i thought party
at this place called south
point with the 70s band
and roger clemens all the everybody's
there
guys are coming up to me just the best
party george this boogie nights is
playing
oh uh these girls are dancing on these
[ __ ] tables there's celebrities
everywhere roger clemens
cheeto everybody's there and cheeto
comes up with a drink goes great great
job papa you call me papa and i said
what do you think bob hope would think
if he saw this he'd go [ __ ] bobble [ __ ]
bob
oh dude i love cheetos they come over to
me and they go
uh
we got to get john out of here what do
you mean look the [ __ ] has his
arms around one of the girl that's
dancing
she's on the thing and he's had his arms
around her legs looking up oh oh oh man
we're trying to get him out of there
yeah
oh boy and he's like georgie no no it's
good i said john we got to go man
and yeah that was thursday friday went
to a party so we're playing saturday on
tv
uh on abc
our time is 10 35 so
you know i get there at [ __ ] 8 30 to
[ __ ] warm up i don't eat yeah i drink
a little bit
[ __ ] some adderall some
[ __ ] i'm [ __ ] going man some red
bull [ __ ] half an adderall i'm
[ __ ] gone
i don't eat the whole day a couple
drinks couple shots we get there me and
sam jackson and luke wilson so we're
warming up 9 30 10 o'clock and sam goes
where's this [ __ ] at i said
he'll be here
our tea time is
10 35 on tv so now you got the officials
coming at 10 10 have you seen your
playing partner no sir he'll be here
though
sam's like that motherfucker's not going
to show up yeah i said he'll be here
10 10
10 15
10 20. now more guys in walkie talkie
show up
10 25
10 28.
georgie
look over
he [ __ ] waves at me he puts his bag
down on the driving range
he takes one ball
puts it on the tee
hits it with the driver it goes [ __ ]
straight he goes
let's go he [ __ ] hit him one golf
ball stayed out all night and drank and
shot
six under yeah
i've never seen anything like that
that's incredible
jake the snake stabler for the raiders
right that dude party all night
get up and throw six touchdowns the next
day and he walked 18 holes
and we laughed and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] we won he's awesome yeah right
and we went to the ceremony on sunday
and nobody came and sam jackson goes yo
[ __ ] i don't think you're going
to be invited back next year i go [ __ ]
neither are you oh i know i'm not i'm
just telling you we're not yeah and we
weren't we weren't invited back
that's why i got kicked out of all the
pro-ams i think because i had fun yeah i
did the [ __ ] that i'd people would love
they had [ __ ] margaritas and yeah we
took shots with people yeah to me
golf is like you gotta have
beer i mean for me this is my own beer
man what do you think i love it oh yes
it's pretty good it's amazing
so those are my can i get more of this
i'll work through some more i mean we
got something back here i mean like
you're not going to buy it somewhere
like if it is website yeah yeah okay
pretty good stories huh yeah
those are incredible
i haven't laughed this much in a long
time i don't haven't had any [ __ ]
the pesci
and the jack nicholson oh oh dude and i
don't even really do jack nicholson no i
don't do impressions but i'll push back
because you yeah yeah
incorporate that or something because
that was funny
when i was really [ __ ] up nobody knows
because you leaned your head back
i don't get it
i'm gonna have to ask you
only
yeah girl give a [ __ ] she's here to [ __ ]
jacob nonetheless
[ __ ] best choice of words
yeah yeah it just shuts it down and jim
gray uh uh goes and sees jack nicholson
every reporter great great guy
and
and jack and i had become good friends
you know towards you know at the later
games and that that thing and he'd go
how's the loper doing
because he calls you the loper [ __ ]
everybody calls me the [ __ ]
that guy is alright
he's the [ __ ] best man because i cuz
because i would
be changing my shoes and his locker was
around the corner
let's get out there and a few balls and
then go get our sticks
you're like that [ __ ] sounds like a
[ __ ]
guy isn't that the best [ __ ]
afternoon yes and i mean he and he
retired from the club man
and and described him with the coke
rings
soaking wet no shirt his hair slicked
back i mean that laying through
that golf shirt was stuck to him the
powder was on his thing he had the two
things and he had that silence of the
lamb [ __ ] hair yeah that was back
like sweaty that [ __ ] ball because
we're in we're getting playing
how about it
anytime you heard that voice it's just
the most unique oh man oh yeah voice and
when i sat next to him at a laker game
and and you would hear him talk to the
ref you're not gonna let him hold the
whole game oh yeah
and you're like wow if i put his hand on
my popcorn he's [ __ ] eating my
popcorn yeah i'm not the ref i mean
amazing [ __ ] man
and i was in a i did rocky horror
picture show at the wilton
like as a favor for lou adler like i
sang and [ __ ] and jack
and me and danny devito shared a uh
dressing room upstairs oh wow oh and for
hours and he was the [ __ ] best man
and when he left
to get in this car
the amount of paparazzi that took
pictures of him lit
because we were up on the second floor
lit the [ __ ] street up like if it was
noon during the day like the amount of
people taking pictures of him yeah
that's incredible that's a whole other
level
of fame it seems like crazy
i'm trying to imagine now what it'd be
like with him and danny devito around
each other oh they were talking about
when they did cuckoo's nest and they
went on the ocean and then oh man and he
uh jack had like this giggle man like a
like a like a chick like a little girl
but so
funny man like a high-pitched he smoked
weed the whole [ __ ] time yeah
and he was the narrator of the thing
highest [ __ ] man
god damn
and even uh arsenio would say that they
would
he goes
he goes uh
hey uh we meet him at the games at
halftime we go in the room and our
senior goes hey uh jack remember we used
to come at the forum and do those cocoa
puffs i don't remember
i used to put
jack had like a one-hitter and they
would put coke and weed and put it in
the oh
and he's [ __ ] arsenio says it like
loud and jacked up i don't remember
he's like [ __ ] ourselves like saying
like hey remember i saw you at that
place where i had lunch and jack was
like hey [ __ ]
we're in public like right right like i
don't remember oh my god but i mean
those were the days like i haven't been
to a laker game
maybe once since kobe retired but
it's different now than yeah like like
for eras like i love that i've loved the
lakers my whole life it's just a
different era now i think even that
president's club where we would all go
drink it at
halftime and after the game
is gone like they turned it they changed
it and then we'll announce crypto.com
it's an officially a new era well have
you been to sofi
i haven't been to so far yeah it looks
cool me either have you been no i've
just seen it and it looks they had to
put um two billion dollars right they
had the super bowl is going to be there
yeah they had to put money in the they
had to put
like
two billion dollars
of
reinforcement in the ground
because the stadium is built on a fault
okay so that stadium is on
built in the ground it's in the ground
yeah there's two billion dollars the guy
goes there's two billion dollars nobody
will see
and it's built so if there's an
earthquake it moves it's built on a
shifting like shock absorbers and two
billion nobody
would see and then the head of
of um
the nfl players
said to us that
they
probably would not ever make the money
back because there's no way that
anybody
um
especially the team like that
unless they won the super bowl multiple
times could ever make that much surplus
to pay for
the overages because they were like
maybe 2 billion over
wow
that's crazy yeah and yeah the rams
yeah and the char and the chargers and
he goes and also he goes you have a team
that's not
you have a team that's not
a home team
that is kind of renting the space that
yeah
do you think they're going to use that
for the olympics aren't there olympics
coming here i think that's the plan they
are and that's what we're talking about
now i just hope they can
kick this covet out because they're now
they're talking about going to dallas
play super bowl i mean if they really if
they because they're extending the
mandate for masks
if they uh if they cancel the grammys
i would assume that the super bowl
you're talking about more people
in suites that it would be in jeopardy
but it's the weird like indoor outdoor
thing that so far has gone on too like
it's it's technically closed but it's
also considered open air like they have
to delay if there's lightning so it's in
the weird like middle ground too so it's
like is it an open-air arena is it
closed
does the does the the roof retract
it's something something like this
i don't know i'll look it up because i'm
talking about my answer but i know
there's something funky to their design
yeah well i mean they could just say
if anyone who comes in here just has to
be vaccinated i mean that's that's what
they're doing on cruise ships i don't
know why they couldn't why they would
cancel the super bowl you know i think
the issue is that you have like you know
the strays man that people that don't
want to yeah totally i mean that's
really what's [ __ ] everything up you
know yeah
that you have the people that are trying
to find some golf pictures here
we had the [ __ ] best times man i used
to work at a golf course that was one of
the first jobs i had i would ride my
bike
i was uh
15 and i ride my bike to this golf
course what was it over there you got
some great courses yeah uh in north
carolina hickory this one was just a
shitty one um but
i saw one of the funniest things this
grounds keeper
was uh trying to show me how to use the
fairway mowers
and how to get uh underneath trees with
the limbs would do like this
yeah you know you got to get up here you
got to kind of duck down and get
underneath the tree and get this big
fairy mower and he comes out and he's
talking like
he goes just like that and then there
was a black snake
on his
and shoulder
and he didn't see it and i was trying to
tell him like you got a snake
he's like why shut up listen to me i'm
like you got a [ __ ] snake on your
shoulder and he looked over and he
flipped out and flung that snake off and
took off
the mower is still going down the
fairway
like that you got a [ __ ] snake on
your shoulder
you're going the wrong way what
uh those were
those that was some hard i mean i had to
push mo i mean i didn't i was too young
to be on those big big ass fairway
mowers but uh that was a you know
pushing the lawnmower uphill
um that was the best shape i was ever
been in ride a bike there didn't push
them all around all day
man
those days man i think those days are
over of of
getting loose like that where
inhibitions were
like nobody had nobody had inhibitions
man
so i did
grab a
blade on a lawnmower
because it it was off he turned it over
and was getting the
wet grass off of the blade clogging it
up and he he just grabbed it went
oh he looked up and he just sliced his
hand
and he looked at it and it took a second
you know for the blood to come out yeah
and he's looking at it it just went
oh my goodness and then he went like
like
yeah yeah
and i thought he was joking i started
laughing at it
but yeah um good times at a at a golf
course i just i was never good at
the woods an iron a putter i got that
i'm going to tell you something about
the wood i'm going to tell you it's a
different swing isn't it no iron it's
not it's supposed to be the same swing
that's why oh maybe i'm [ __ ] that up
but but
the remember the girl was here a couple
weeks ago when we were last time we were
here and she
it what's her name when you were the one
you banged that night
uh the the
the i said to her hey listen i'm doing
the laugh back tomorrow if you
are if you want to offer you a spot she
did good didn't she yeah yeah oh yeah
what's her name
okay from sounds like a cult off them
sounds like a cult and this is what i'm
going to say to you
my tournament is the first monday in may
okay and if you can
if you're comfortable with it i would
love for you to play well okay i'm
practicing now okay there you go i'm
coming and there it is
i'm putting it in first
monday first weekend of my first monday
oh monday good deal
at uh lakeside i'll have to uh postpone
my podcast recording for that day okay
what did anybody do why does everybody
do mondays
oh yeah all right what how many what was
that an hour and a half already yeah
goddamn that was fun dude that burned by
and you know we don't even really like
start we just started well i didn't i
was like i didn't know if you're doing
like an intro no we were just oh just
started talking oh yeah yeah you never
introduced no no i mean like for the
show even like a no show yeah yeah it's
also like we have a pre-record stuff
that goes up top but uh that's great
thank you for joining us comedian
podcast and actor john reeve my
absolute pleasure 100 it's awesome to
meet you man and uh yes it's good to see
you dude yeah likewise
uh we might use those stories let's see
here what i feel like i was going to ask
you like this i don't know dude those
are probably some of the best we've
gotten on here yeah
i didn't know you did impressions i
don't i mean that's the thing
that came out of left field
yeah yeah you're a good storyteller but
damn the impression yeah there are three
extra people in the room
there's some wild shoot man i see some
wild [ __ ]
stop talking after that just like i'm
gonna sit back and look this is [ __ ]
great
god damn i mean
the [ __ ] we couldn't play through
that [ __ ] thing
i was like painted the picture i saw the
coconut oh
nevertheless
nonetheless that's right we're gonna
play through that's good uh you wanna
tell the people they can find you
instagram if there's anything to shout
out your podcast stuff yeah i also have
a podcast on this very network all
things comedy it is called country-ish
i'll do it check it out please do yeah
we'll go over there and do it i'd do it
in north carolina so it'd be a zoom
situation but y'all could do that oh is
it so you live over there i moved back
three years ago because my dad had a
stroke and uh
and now he's paralyzed on his left side
lives in a skilled nursing facility my
mom has never lived by herself
so i went home to park it with mom for a
second then the pandemic happens it's a
true bone
fast man like that and but at the same
time i was happy to be able
to have this kind of a job or life where
i could just get up and go and not worry
about like you know a real job or
anything like that you know just leave
and i could we could do this anywhere i
mean this microphone i have the same one
in north carolina so so when when uh
let's talk a little bit about i want to
ask you guys i was over there at the
same time
so rodney carrington yeah i was on his
sitcom was was a [ __ ] huge comedian
yes huge wait did you produce that i
produced freddy but i was over there at
that same time and i thought right that
rodney's show was going to be huge
because he
everybody loved him
he was a [ __ ] great comedian
yeah and he had a show at abc and i
thought perfect man this dude is going
to be and the the lead in was according
to jim
and he kept like 99.9 percent of that
audience no one changed the channel when
rodney came on so which is a good mark
of a
success i remember i saw him at the
upfront yeah
uh and you played his friend i played
the cop gerald bob so i was like a
semi-regular i was there like one uh
like every third episode i'd pop on but
it god that was the best job i've ever
had in my life it's my best [ __ ] job
man because i mean
so what happened to so who was it was i
on that night did you look and see what
year was that
let's see what that was uh let's see
2005 yeah
2005. the lineup that abc was yeah i'll
see if i can find it yeah i want to say
you you might have all been on the same
night um
you guys at 9 30. i went to
what's that now were you guys 9 30
tuesday uh it was tuesday yeah it was
tuesday i don't remember exactly it may
have been whatever after after recording
gym whatever whatever time that was
that was the best [ __ ] job i ever had
in my life where did you guys shoot that
at disney no uh cbs radford and i bought
a condo right across the river if you
want to come on the other little river
there yeah and i could see the studio i
could walk
there and back and that's one way to get
a show canceled by a house within
walking distance they will cancel it for
you every time but yeah it was who
played his wife uh uh jennifer aspen
jennifer aspen was his wife
nick seriously was his buddy i was a cop
that was like in love with his wife so
he kind of hated me but we got along
like this man rodney rodney is and was
one of the funniest dudes ever and what
happened to the what happened he got
canceled it did two seasons um and you
know i don't want to i'm not sure
exactly but i've heard him tell me
different stories about what happened he
was making a lot of money on the road
before this sitcom
yeah
and a lot of money yeah i mean he was
selling out in doubt you know texas and
the southwest do you think it hurt them
after the show got cancelled i mean it
had to have i think it did i think
totally i mean he was on a prime time
network show and then now he's that's
not he's gone i know but he still does
well
i just
opened for him not long ago and
somewhere in kentucky some big outdoor
arena is packed
um i don't know i don't know how that
happens but but i thought it totally had
to i felt like it hurt it hurt him uh
and also foxworthy i mean was anybody
more popular than foxworthy at an nbc
show and that didn't go right his his
only went like
one and a half seasons or something i
mean we had two possibly we're going to
do
they were going to they was going to do
it but they canceled it because of the
ratings or because of the
new guy came in
uh some new guy a show runner dude not a
showrunner but like at the network came
in the guy who liked rodney who hired
rodney at abc disney
left
and so a new guy came in and he's like
what's this redneck [ __ ] i don't get it
what is this mcpherson and then rodney
had to take a meeting with him and it
didn't go well
and uh you know this is rodney this is
my favorite story is what rodney told me
he said
i
we had this meeting on the books several
times and they kept canceling it one day
it was this reason
next day it's a jewish holiday we can't
do this over here
and so he he said the third meeting he
was
tired of this and he walked in and he
was wearing like shorts flip-flops i had
a [ __ ] big gulp
and he walked in he said if you guys
would quit this silly religion would get
some work done around here
and they're like
what are you doing yeah he's like what
are we doing what is this
and they're like we don't need this
because i don't need that and it just
they didn't need each other and he had
it you know rodney does things his own
ways you know he's
um
i wouldn't say stubborn but he likes
things done his way it's not an easy
thing to it's not easy
every day
every hour is
[ __ ] some [ __ ] that's happening man
yeah yeah like i i remember watching tim
allen before tool time
when his showtime special was on and he
did like an hour it was [ __ ]
brilliant like seamless
and everything that became home
improvement was in that hour and we're
sitting in the back of the room in
indianapolis with a comedy connection
and thinking i don't have that like i'm
not even i don't have five minutes of
that [ __ ] never thinking that
i wasn't disciplined to and then i don't
know what happened but
you could see the direction of his
career going where it went i mean you
know he did improvement it was number
one
did the movies you could see it you
could see it you could see it and
having a show like my show has been on
it'll be 20 years at the end of [ __ ]
march wow and
not
i mean it was
enjoyable i never thought it would
happen put me on the map but
none of it was relaxing at all yeah none
of it
and that's when the ratings came out at
10 like they weren't immediate the guy
would walk down with the papers and we'd
look at them yeah and we were all right
on the line and then the last three
years i was up against american idol oh
and i still survived 120. yeah but it
was
something that is not the easiest dude
if your name is on the sitcom if it's
your sitcom
i don't know how you sleep yeah i mean
it's it's something always right always
something's happening
why i loved it wasn't my second i could
just come on and steal a scene and get
the hell out of there and especially
working at radford is [ __ ]
yeah great walk over to gg studios
uh i think different nights it looks
like um
were you wednesdays they [ __ ] had me
every i was on friday i'm trying to find
it because it moves around but you're
definitely on the same time because it
was abc from 2004 to 2006. okay yeah
yeah three years and that at least
premiered on a tuesday i don't know if
it's still there but yeah oh you guys
were definitely you're right around each
other yeah
it's good to meet you man likewise and
come back thank you and let's see
may 1st it's in the calendar
i love it yeah
you're coming
are you going to be there
dude i got to work out my coffee you
weren't at the other one were you
i know it wasn't the other one but i
also can't go for [ __ ] so i got to work
on that yeah i'll have you on
country-ish sometimes right now i'll do
it zoom in i'll do it awesome
all right touchdown well done man that
was [ __ ] that was the best it's great
yeah
you